après celle de rambouiller il y a un an
le centre hospitalier Jean-Martin
Charcot de plaisir a inauguré une
nouvelle structure de psychiatrie
infantau juvénil en plein centreville de
morpa elle regroupe l'ancienne structure
de morpa plus la structure de la
verrière qui a été rapatrié ici pour
fusionner les équipes et donner un plus
un plateau technique mieux équipé et
plus plus agréable aux enfants au total
1000 enfants et adolescents atteints de
troubles mentaux qui sont accueillis
quotidiennement pour des consultation ou
des ateliers thérapeutiques pour prendre
en charge leur pathologie C médecins
pédopsychiatres et une trentaine de
personnel médical dont un nouveau
psychologue à mi-temps ces nouveaux
locaux aménagés sur 600 m Carr sont
considérés comme un atout en plus on a
un mobilier qui est adapté donc tout est
s roulette on le pousse on peut mettre
dans les couloirs on exploite la sol sol
si on veut l'atelier lumineux permet
aussi d'utiliser plus de matériel et de
développer des projets avec les
adolescents des projets parfois
étonnants c'est peut-être le seul
endroit ici où ils savent que c'est pour
eux et que ils vont pouvoir amener leur
projet comme ils veulent et que les gens
travaillent voilà avec eux à leur
service on le fait faire des armes en
carton des cartons de récupération pour
tirer des élastiques par exemple et leur
apprendre ainsi
comme maîtriser la violence ce pôle de
pédopsychiatrie concerne 90 communes qui
s'étendent de 50 en iveline jusqu'à
rambouiller